MRI is a medical imaging device
commonly used to examine
the soft tissues of the human body
Let's meet the machine.
The key components are
Our bodies are made up of 60% water
and water is magnetic.
Each of the billions
of water molecules inside us
consists of an oxygen atom
bonded to two hydrogen atoms.
We know it as H2O.
Small parts of the hydrogen atoms act as tiny magnets
and are very sensitive to magnetic fields.
MRI stands for magnetic resonance imaging
and an MRI scanner is one of the
main diagnostic tools that doctors use
to examine inside our bodies.
The first step in taking an MRI scan is to use a
big magnet to produce a unified magnetic
field around the patient.
The gradient adjusts the magnetic field
into smaller sections
of different magnetic strengths
to isolate specific body parts.
For example, the brain.
Normally the water
molecules inside us are arranged randomly.
But when we lie inside the magnetic field
most of our water
molecules move at the same rhythm or
frequency as the magnetic field.
The ones that don't move along the magnetic field
are called low energy water molecules.
To create an image of a body part,
for example the brain,
the machine focuses on the
low energy water molecules.
Radio waves move at the same
rhythm or frequency as the magnetic
fields in an MRI machine.
By sending
radio waves that match or resonate with
the magnetic field the low energy water
molecules absorb the energy they need to
move alongside the magnetic field.
When the machine stops emitting radio
waves the water molecules that had just
moved along the magnetic field release
the energy they had absorbed and go back
to their position.
This movement is
detected by the MRI machine and the
signal is sent to a powerful computer
which uses imaging software to translate
the information into an image of the
body.
By taking images of the body in
each section of the magnetic field the
machine produces a final three
dimensional image of the organ which
doctors can analyze to make a diagnosis.